[Música]
momento de hablar de salud aquí en
France 24 nos acompaña ya en el estudio
más Romero sala bienvenida Gracias Rosa
Buenos días mar vamos a hablar de la
situación particularmente en Haití Sí
vamos a hacer una actualización del
brote de escalera que vive en el país
porque han salido nuevas cifras y no nos
podemos olvidar de que el país está
atravesando una verdadera emergencia
este brote empezó el 2 de octubre de
2022 tuvo el primer caso después de casi
tres años sin detectar esta enfermedad y
ahora después de estos ocho meses más de
ocho meses son
743 las víctimas mortales las personas
que han fallecido a raíz del cólera de
las cuales además 329 que es más de un
40% fallecieron sin haber llegado a
tener nunca atención sanitaria algo que
muestra la dificultad de acceder a los
centros de salud de acceder a la
atención en un país que está como
sabemos pues atravesando también una
crisis política social económica y donde
hay bandas armadas que están controlando
gran parte del territorio
un poco también el movimiento digamos
para recibir atenciones sanitarias
parece que el pico de contagio te está
bajando que llegó a su máximo a finales
de 2022 Pero eso no quita no que Este
brote no esté claramente bajo control en
total son
47.000 los casos de presunto cólera que
se están contando personas que sean
enfermedades enfermado perdón recordemos
que la enfermedad tiene vacunas una
vacuna oral que sirve para aplicarse las
comunidades que están en riesgo no tiene
protección a largo plazo pero sí cuando
aparece un brote se envió la Ops envió
más de un millón de vacunas en 2022 en
2023 Se recibió medio millón más pero
por ejemplo médicos Sin fronteras que
trabaja ahí denuncian que se necesita
más que se necesita también protección
contra varios ataques que están
recibiendo y que dificultan por lo tanto
que ellos también puedan desarrollar
esta labor de administrar vacunas o
administrar atención sanitaria a las
personas que están enfermas Mari
claramente en Haití acceder a la
atención sanitaria es particularmente
difícil pero Pero hay brotes de cólera
en todo el mundo sí estamos viviendo una
situación sin precedentes dicen no las
organizaciones internacionales como la
OMS son 18 países al menos los que
tienen un brote de cólera activo en este
momento la mayoría están en países del
continente africano como vemos en este
mapa en América Latina destacamos por
supuesto el tigre al país del que
estábamos hablando pero también hay un
centenar de casos que se han detectado
en el país con el que comparte isla en
República Dominicana y además es un
momento pues particularmente importante
para destacar que este resurgimiento
global de la enfermedad se alimenta al
final de las crisis humanitarias también
vemos por ejemplo destacados en el mapa
Siria vemos Líbano vemos bangladesh que
son países que tienen crisis de
refugiados por ejemplo muy enquistadas
en su cotidianidad y en su situación
diaria y esta enfermedad que se
transmite al ingerir agua que esté o
alimentos que estén contaminados no con
una con una bacteria que provoca la
enfermedad que se encuentra en los des
derechos de las personas que están
enfermas nos muestra al final que se
puede solucionar con acceso agua potable
con buen saneamiento con buenas
instalaciones de higiene al final estas
son enfermedades que son fáciles de
combatir pero que cuando hay una crisis
humanitaria todo esto se cae un poco no
se cae a pedazos y por lo tanto es el
caldo de cultivo perfecto para para la
enfermedad que además está teniendo una
mortalidad más alta de lo habitual un 2%
3% en países africanos cuando Debería
ser alrededor de menos del 1% Mari
precisamente sobre higiene y saneamiento
se conocieron hoy unas cifradas
alarmantes No sí la Organización Mundial
de la salud pública un informe de la
mano de unicef también bajo una premisa
Y es que se pueden salvar millones de
Vidas ahorrar también millones de
recursos de dineros solo con que las
instalaciones de salud tengan buen
acceso a agua buena higiene de manos
acceso también a baños Incluso en algo
que parece tan básico vemos que la mitad
de los centros de salud registrados en
el mundo no tienen un buen sistema de
higiene de manos algo que es básico que
el 80% sólo tiene agua corriente en sus
instalaciones eso significa que un 20%
no la tiene y además en países de África
subsahariana ese porcentaje aumenta al
50% y que sólo el 90% también todavía
falta esa parte tienen baños acceso a
baños algo que es básico para una
atención sanitaria de calidad para
combatir problemas como la resistencia
antibacterial también para combatir la
mortalidad infantil y materna en los
momentos del parto no evitar infecciones
y por supuesto también para evitar
enfermedades como el cólera que era
precisamente la que estábamos hablando
que con un buen acceso a baños y un buen
acceso agua potable se solucionan
bastante fácil Marcos Muchas gracias por
este clarísimo panorama sobre la
situación del cólera y le pido para
cerrar esta Crónica que bueno un
comentario sobre que hoy es el día del
donante de sangre Sí vamos a terminar
con un breve Recordatorio a una cifra
simplemente una donación puede llegar a
salvar tres vidas
eso es muy importante Por eso invitamos
a todo el mundo a que hoy podamos ir a
donar sangre pero también te digo que
los glóbulos rojos que es una de las
partes más importantes de La donación de
sangre se almacenan Por poco tiempo
duran unas seis semanas así que rosa si
no puedes ir hoy podemos ir en los
próximos días y será igual de útil
porque es especialmente importante como
decíamos que estas donaciones sucedan
día tras día de forma cotidiana y no
solamente en días como hoy Yo soy
donante de sangre Mar tú también creo no
Estrellita dorada Rosa